but I'm interested in the way in the
other thing which is he raised the
question of all this dystopian science
fiction going on in the so-called Golden
Age of science fiction was very kind of
upbeat utopian and you know from Star
Maker which is about this utopian as it
gets
and he was kind of you totally socialist
and whatnot generational concerns seem
to have this kind of countervailing the
counter they're like I want to be the
mirror to the understandings that I grew
up with and so the understandings that a
lot of Golden Age folks grew up with
there was a world war that was
truly awful it was really devastating
talk about dystopia she says burn a lot
of the major cities in the world right
to the ground they look through that and
but the front just opions didn't grow up
or anything like that they grew up with
technology getting better and better the
economics getting better better and all
the steven pinker world getting better
and better of childbirth is not killing
women the way it used to do all over the
world basically people getting out of
poverty is the main event in the world
and these guys are doing worl just got
damn minute and then telling the counter
story is the counter story part of what
science fiction people do I actually
think we have a kind of Soviet level of
dystopia is if you went and you hung out
in the Soviet Union you can make the
same arguments it's like well you know
actually there's there's more roads and
like there's better buildings and like
the food is improved a lot since World
War two so you know why are you actually
like happy and upbeat about being a
Soviet right it like in the writers
union they're like rewarded for that as
I wrote a great novel about a tractor
and honestly they really brought in the
crop so you know this is it's super you
know but it was the lies that corroded
people's morale and I think that's our
actual problem now people are dystopia
because they know that the major
problems we face are P pay for it over
right that they're just not we're not
dealing with the problems that we have
so there's like a loss of legitimacy
among
institutions and you've got people who
basically are dystopian but they're
dystopian in the level of life Soviet
guys mumbling black humor jokes to one
another you know while while avoiding
the situation right
and you know I'd like to make historical
analogies but they don't they don't
always work perfectly or well and you
know there there are a lot of people in
Russia right now who are actually pretty
upbeat about the situation even though I
mean they're proud right they really
feel like they're off their deathbed and
kind of you know laying out with two
fists I mean they're they're they're
ethno nationalists Russian enthusiasts
and a lot of them are Christian
fundamentalist Orthodox Christian
fundamentalism and they do this even
though there's like a snowstorm of
official lies from the regime I mean
they just lie about everything routinely
sitting like guys with nerve gas at
London I mean they're lying so openly
and with such brazen lack of good faith
that it's almost like gloating and
they're actually clothing with the lies
at this point right so you know Russians
used to be the most dystopian sci-fi
writers especially if they escaped
Russia
whereas now the most optimistic winds
are probably Chinese you know you know
and you would not want to go to China
and so they'd say oh what a great place
I mean you know I have well you know
normally you would not say I'm going to
China for like the better way of life
that they have you know the Chinese
sci-fi writers are just like punching
way above their weight right now
and this really is their Golden Age of
you know science fiction and they're not
writing dystopian stuff in fact they're
writing just really pretty good novels I
mean things that are kind of have
emotional depth and they've got vision
and they're they're not comic book II or
stupid they're not serving the regime
they're not they're really literate
tours you know I was like they can
really do it you know they're like
they're in they're in they're in pretty
good shape
right so you know how are you gonna
explain that okay I don't know I don't
have like a grand theory but it
interests me a lot that they're around
and they're not they're not utopia I
mean utopia thing is overblown I mean
people who wrote commercial science
fiction intended to write stuff without
beating
especially in the US but the best-known
works of imagined in fantasy are 1984
Brave New World and you know other very
serious somber kind of geopolitical
novels are all about oppression and
torture and official lies and you know
in deceit and hate and murderer and you
know phone enos and so forth and these
are the things that really mean these
are the ones that are kind of sunk down
on the cultural level you see Orwellian
around you would see Palardy and around
you don't really seem Buck Rogers II and
you know it just seems childish so I
don't know I mean it's a matter of
temperament
you know guys of my era I mean cyber
punks were into dark euphoria and kind
of we're not into a sense of wonder
we're into like ecstasy and Dre okay I
mean ecstasy and red is stuff that you
see a lot in cyberpunk tanks it's like
it's really horrible and I like oh but
really really amazing like I'm also
really horrible but like just fantastic
I can't get my head around it it's like
except this legs been sawn off you know
and it's like and this is kind of a very
deliberate period sensibility that you
know sort of emerged from the 1980s and
you know you could see it didn't film
and the way people dressed and you know
that kind of thing and you know it was
fun to do that's kind of hadn't didn't
try it out but I don't have I don't have
a magic solution for it and I also don't
think that optimistic science fiction
actually makes anybody optimistic I
don't think that helps I don't think
that helps with the problem at all
I mean what makes people optimistic is
something to be enthusiastic about
that's why that's when people are really
optimistic they don't even ask if
they're in a good mood they just hop out
of bed because they might want to go do
it and we don't have a lot of things to
be optimistic to be enthusiastic about
like Moore's Law was something or the
internet was something but this is like
your uncle's job now we don't have like
something that like really makes people
like pop out and make it happen and if
we did the oligarchs you know would hit
it on the head or buy it
or suppress it in some way and I think
people know that so that's the actual
mm-hmm that's the actual what's the
right word for it
malaise that's the that's the Carter s
malaise of our era were not authentic
[Music]